[Music]
hello
hello
hello
[Music]
hello and we're here this is the first
episode of lifeline we did it a lot of
you guys
first of all i'm krista leah
i'm matt dalia a lot of you guys really
really uh loved the episodes of
congratulations
uh
where matt was in and you guys kept
begging me to have matt back but i
by design right we didn't do it by
design yeah because one day we were
gonna do a podcast and today's the day
yeah today's the day where the first
podcast comes out it's called lifeline
and it's the first podcast about you
because you call in and you ask for
advices
and
and then we help you advise us and we
help you because we're we're both what
really good at giving advice i'm really
good at giving advice thank you so i've
been told i don't mean to toot my own
horn
don't say thank you when i say something
about myself you're saying both of us
most no
i think i
be based on what people have told me
throughout the course of my life and how
much people have sought specifically my
advice
i have the feeling i have a feeling a
strong feeling based on
past what i would say is evidence that i
am good at giving advice okay and i
don't know if that's true about you
because what have people said about me
about anybody i don't know because i
don't ask you for okay well nobody's
told me well you you could you probably
have asked me for advice in the past but
also people probably
have told you that they've gotten advice
from me i don't know what they said and
honestly i can't remember a time where
people said that to me that hey your
brother's really good at giving advice
i'm not saying you're not but i'm saying
your own horn right yeah and then also
like
well no one's ever
talked to me about seeking advice from
you because that would be such a boring
[ __ ] person what why would they do
that because it was exactly brother
that's my problem
yeah because you brought it up as if
that would be a normal thing but it is
not it would kind of be boring to just
be like hey man i got advice from
somebody just
and then whatever that conversation will
go would probably be a boring
conversation yes
okay cool
so but that's what this podcast is it is
yes it's an advice
show
similar or at least in the spirit of
what we grew up on which was
whoops that you cut me off no but an ode
to because you you could have just
summed that up by saying you know i
wanted to burn into almost i did it and
i think the way that i did it was great
but what it is an homage to an ode to is
the old show love line right dr drew and
adam corolla used to be on late at night
i think k rock right yes right and it
was all like weird sort of
secretive sex stuff right that people
could anonymously call in and seek their
advice on sex
while it can be about sex
is the it's about anything and
everything that might come up in your
life but uh you know the title of the
show
lifeline yeah uh is sort of uh uh an ode
or an homage or an oman so what what
happened was you were saying all the
words then i said odor homage and you
got mad at me for cutting off and now
you're only using the words
just doing that to highlight how
annoying it was that you did it i'm i'm
no i'm not like it's not like i'm being
facetious but i'm yeah underscore i'm
underlining i'm highlighting it and the
way that i'm saying it is to sort of not
belittle you as much as it is to point
out how annoying it was that you tried
to tell me how to talk i have a huge
[ __ ]
i'll say it okay so no one was yeah no i
know but i'm saying when you come at me
in that way i have to make it even by
talking about stuff that's good about me
anyway
it's okay who cares right that's a
really really really dumb
thing in general
and also not a good
way to argue okay well no one even gives
a [ __ ] anyway because they're not
[ __ ] 12. do you think people don't
care about
um penis size guys do for sure that's
the thing heterosexual
men do seem to care about penis size but
what i hear from women when i talk to
them is that they actually
don't care it's about the way that you
use it it's about the way that you use
it
yes
same note all the whole time
yeah it goes it's in the way that you
use it but you just went it's in the way
that you use it like a [ __ ] one i
like this segment no no but wait so i
did it on purpose but here's how you
know that actually
uh
huge [ __ ] matter okay
because
you haven't aren't taking into the
[ __ ] gays you aren't taking into the
gays the gay guys will always tell you
what's up right and you're saying gay
guys
care about dick size right and you know
that's but here's the thing if you're a
heterosexual man
then
when you talk to women about penis size
they say that they don't care so you
can't say because gay men do care that
dick size matters because it's not
true in a blanket way for everyone
women are saying in in their vaginas it
doesn't i mean obviously there are some
women that say it does matter but i
think in my experience the vast majority
of women that i've spoken to about it
say it's not about the size as much as
it's about it's in the way that you use
it i think mostly there it's the thing
it in that song is your personality
because your personality is the sexiest
i know it's not about dick size but
that's what i'm saying when you
i mean
i wasn't concerned the way that you use
it
and then the [ __ ] your dick right no
it's not that it's not that it's i'm
saying it's in the way that you use i
know the song isn't about that but i'm
saying it's in the way that you use it
what we're talking about is we're
talking about the personality because if
you're trying to
i think that the opposite sex for you
know for us female they like the way
that we use it the personality no no no
no it's in the way that you use your
dick no i understand that's what you're
saying okay but what i'm saying is if
your personality is really good you have
a higher chance of being banging in the
bedroom uh because i mean i don't know
is about everything up until you have
sex not just when you're in the bed
yeah but a lot of winners
we'll tell we'll we'll talk about how oh
he's such an [ __ ] or he's an idiot or
he's such a [ __ ] lunk head but the
sex is so good you hear that all the
time but that's why it's so good because
that is his personality and that is it
and she doesn't know she's attracted by
it which is him being an [ __ ] having
a leather jacket and smoking around his
head like no no because if he was bad at
sex she wouldn't be having sex with him
no so the bottom line is it's in the way
that you use it the reason why he's good
at sex is because he's unlocking the
secret part and doesn't and and she
doesn't know that she likes bad boys and
this bad boy comes along and she's like
uh he's such an [ __ ] but really he's
a [ __ ] he's awesome in the sack and
the reason why he's awesome in the sack
is because she secretly he unlocked the
[ __ ] about how she really likes bad boys
no it's about the way that you move
around you got the rotation
you can use your hips in a certain way
no it's like dancing
are you good at dancing do you have
rhythm are you in tune with the person's
body
things like this not about how you
[ __ ] smoke a cigarette around your
head no it is honestly about okay it is
about also
the way you do circular motions yes
right but also that's like ten percent
of it ninety percent of it is how you
show up to dinner and the way you're
holding your drink yeah could that
possibly be the case and the way you're
well you're having sex no one's thinking
about oh he was so cool at dinner the
way he used his fork you're not thinking
about it there's no way that he uses
fork no
i mean it has nothing to do with you it
doesn't have nothing do you think
honestly it has nothing to do with it no
but to use the ten percent that you use
i would say that's for that if that that
would be at the top if i show up the
most that could count is ten percent
okay if i show up in a beat-up old
classic car that it looks like i kind of
am working on i didn't really take care
of it yet right it's not all of what my
personality is but i sure like doing it
in the daytime i like getting the parts
every now and then some of them i get
shipped over from amazon some of them i
go to [ __ ] carports
you're never having sex you can inside
you can get this [ __ ] inside if you want
to get like a [ __ ] handle for the
thing whatever it is dude i'm a guy who
doesn't really think about my car that
much but i do like it as a hobby in the
daytime i'm fixing up my old car i also
guess what take care of my mom i take
care of my mom who's in a [ __ ] house
who's in an assisted living home i don't
know if she's gonna be alive for that
much longer but i [ __ ] love her and
that's what's up and then when i come to
dinner we're hanging out having a good
time i tell you about my sis my mom and
her assistant living how she's my life
and how i [ __ ] take care of her i
also tell you about my car that i
[ __ ] get parts from and it's not my
whole life but i'm working on it and one
day i'm gonna get the car really nice
dude and that's why when you hit the
bedroom
it's much better because you're
interested and you've unlocked all that
mystery but
no to all of that and she would
immediately be thinking about how do i
get out of here should i say i'm going
to the bathroom and just [ __ ] dip if
you talked about your [ __ ] mom and
assisted living and then how you take
care of your car in the daytime yeah
she's [ __ ]
gone why because that's so boring that's
so nice though if you're like yeah my
mom's in assisted living and i just take
care of her dude and oh that car now i
know it's [ __ ] a little rusty but i
got to get the panel [ __ ] refurbished
because everything got [ __ ] up and i
got some parts on amazon you're on the
worst date you are providing
whoever you're on a date with with the
worst [ __ ] date i'm just saying dude
foreplay is all up until the actual
moment in bed
the the point sex is not about sex it's
the way that you use
the your
moves it's not just your dick anyway
it's not your it's your moves
it's the moves it's the moves it's the
moves a a big dick helps i'm not saying
that if you move it slowly
if it if it will also everyone's
different though everyone's so it's in
the way that you use it on the person
you're having sex with okay so right
yeah i'm just saying sex is all about
everything except for sex so that's some
advice that i would give to somebody if
they were calling but let's take the
first call you want to take the first
call yeah you don't forgot to do the
disclaimer oh right okay let's do the
discussion
uh so basically
this is an advice show and that is the
idea and we will always be taking the
advice of people who send in their
videos and submissions and all that
that being said
it should never ever be mistaken for
as good as or some kind of replacement
for actual professional
medical psychiatric advice if you have a
real problem you should see a real
doctor uh and and and basically not us
this is basically
for entertainment purposes only and if
you have a real problem go to therapy i
go to therapy i've been going for
[ __ ] i don't even know 12 years i
have five therapists and chris has five
therapists and as we just learned he
[ __ ] needs every last one of them
right and uh but yeah if you have a real
problem
please seek out real
actual
professional help yeah thank you now i
also have five therapists and you don't
need to say every last one because
there's only five it's not like 150 but
anyway five is more than anyone
i mean like [ __ ]
idi amin would need five therapists i
think honestly i mean is he alive still
i don't even know actually that's the
craziest [ __ ] name there is we talk
about
don't get me wrong yeah you know i mean
you talk about the guy the guy in the
outlaws the tupac's group no i'm talking
about idi i mean right okay the the guy
there was a guy there was an outlaw guy
in tupac's group called idiamin anyway
for real yeah you didn't know that yeah
that's terrible i mean the you know
rappers they do that
[ __ ] going by pol pot
joseph stalin the rapper you know
they'll be [ __ ] gucci castro like
there will be
yeah okay so let's go let's go let's get
our first caller
oh hey guys so i have a conundrum that
really can't go unaddressed um i mean
i've been friends with this guy for a
really long time i trust him with my
life
we've been through thick and thin
together but here's the situation i
start talking to this girl right and
because i trust him
i give him my phone so we can look
through her pictures on facebook why now
the thing is
we know that there are unwritten rules
when it comes to this exchange and
absolutely under no circumstance can you
like an old picture from a girl's
facebook
not even instagram where a double tap is
something that could you have to hit the
thumbs up to a point where i just have
to trust that my good friend knows these
rules but this is a type of blunder that
really can't go unpunished
so my question for you is what should
his punishment be to fully recompense
for this abhorrent offense so he did it
so he did that his friend did that yeah
his friend went back
into first of all thank you thank you
for your submission yeah great shirt too
yeah and i mean it's an ace ventura
shirt pretty much but but it's a great
shirt now i'm not saying it's not good i
love aventura but so hold on so his
friend
don't first of all don't ever give your
friend your phone well that's what i was
going to say yeah
i would lead with this is 100 his fault
in the first place his fault
yeah yeah
you you it's one of those things where
like you made your bed what did you
expect you gave your friend who you
would
uh trust with your life who you said you
would trust with your life but also just
because you would trust somebody with
their your life doesn't mean you should
trust them with your phone as a matter
of fact i would say i would trust a
stranger more with my phone than my
friend because my friend's gonna be like
playing a joke yeah my other question if
we had him on the phone would be is does
he did he do it as a joke or did he do
it by mistake
i think he's implying that he did it uh
on purpose and i guess as a joke or as
like a uh uh i don't know prank i don't
know what the right word would be but he
did it to like yeah needle his friend i
don't know that's kind of funny and i
don't fault the friend i fault him
because no no dude hold on
i've i've done both i've given someone
my phone to look at it on whatever i'm
looking at yeah i don't think i've done
it with like a a girl that i'm
interested in yeah but i've done that
and
and and i've also been on the other side
of like let me see your phone yeah and i
i i
i agree with that unwritten thing you
don't [ __ ]
click things as someone else on their
phone i agree with that too but it's
it's
it's it's it's still
his fault for giving it
to his friend right right but that being
said
just because that is true that can what
can be separately also true is that the
friend
doing that
isn't funny
that's not funny
who's who's laughing no it's not funny
well he hit the friend who did it that's
it though but
things that you do to only make yourself
laugh at the expense of one or more
people that's never funny that is not
funny interesting so the way to get back
at him if
first of all i fully truly and i'm sure
you disagree i fully truly don't believe
in getting back at people i don't like
that i don't think that's the right way
to think about stuff that being said
this [ __ ] seems hell-bent on
getting right right right and i i
wouldn't fault him for that just because
i wouldn't do it doesn't mean that if he
feels the need to do it then [ __ ] it in
a way it's like you him hitting the like
button on that facebook post or picture
is the same thing as this guy giving him
his phone it's like well dude you kind
of [ __ ] you should expect him to be
retaliated you should actually expect
retaliation no right
the way to retaliate if that's what you
are bent on doing as this is ventura
sure yeah family seems to do seems to
believe is i think that he should
do
the exact same thing when it comes to
like revenge or getting back at someone
i think people do it wrong i think if
you're going to do it you got to do the
same thing yeah otherwise you escalate
into a war that nobody [ __ ] wants
right and then you know look at what
happened in ukraine and russia
yeah well that's a real war i'm using
the word as like i'm saying it started
it could have started with something
really minuscule like this so like you
think
zelensky
took putin's phone no and liked a
picture of some russian girl
and that's how that's how we ended up
where we are in ukraine no i think that
well this started probably way before
facebook but it could have been
something like you know it did yeah you
you're encroaching
and the guy's like oh i don't mean to
and he's like yeah but and then he goes
back and he's like son of [ __ ]
encroached wow so has no [ __ ] idea no
idea what's going on in ukraine you know
what i mean i do and he's like i know
that's just but you know and then he's
like i should encroach back you know
[ __ ] this yeah right i mean this is not
how it worked no i know and the guy's
like yeah he encroached and then the
guys are like he encroached but they
didn't mean to maybe just encroach a
little bit nuts in same amount right and
then they were like yes maybe same
amount but also we have to take it step
further and so he took it a step further
and approached a little bit more because
to also with interest and then later on
now there's this huge [ __ ] war and
it's like genocide first of all
encouragement has nothing to do with
what's going on
or the video always has to do with
what's going on
you just learned what the word
encroachment means earlier today and
encroachment honestly and i and i mean
this 100
has to do with mostly every problem in
the world
okay
name one problem that doesn't have to do
with encroachment
name one problem and don't say cancer of
course well no i don't i can't turn
crosses in your body okay so there we go
a problem in the world
hunger world hunger how does that what
does it have to do with encroachment
hunger is well yeah that's one of those
ones that's probably not okay well that
was very easy and it was the first one i
thought of so between cancer and
wholeness and hunger there's one that's
not the homeless and the cancer thing
does have to do with encroachment anyway
how does cancer have to do with
encroachment what is it encroaches in
your body and it's [ __ ] okay that's
such a [ __ ] stretch
okay so anyway back to the turret in
this world i think if you insi if you
must the war on encroachment retaliate
stop saying encroachment
you must retaliate the way to brutality
is just to do the same thing back but
again that's going to be tricky the
guy's not gonna give you his phone you
gotta like get
smart about it and gotta figure out a
way to get his phone i don't like it i
think this is look my advice to you is
to let it go and and learn the lesson
i don't think you
should and she gifted you a lesson you
learned a lesson you learned a lesson
you were too innocent and this is
honestly not even the thing it's like
you didn't
you know
you just learned oh oh you know what you
did oh you gave him the phone oh he
liked the thing you go you take the
phone back and you say oh i just
uh um
i just learned you're an enemy you go
like that yeah i just fell i just oops
oopsie daisy yeah my enemies are exposed
now right and you're one of them that's
what he did right yes so so we go okay
and that's fine and i want you to
understand that now i know that and that
is terrifying to that dude yeah right
now i'm not going to get you back or i
am going to get you back but guess what
if i am going to get you back it's not
going to be today yeah it might be
another day yeah and you live with that
dude yeah and you mess with his sleep
patterns moving forward yeah he doesn't
know what to do he tries to sleep with
one eye open which is as we all know not
possible but so um
i think honestly uh
you just basically
uh you're [ __ ] up by giving the guy
your phone you never give anybody your
phone period that's like giving
literally like giving somebody and you
know what it's like it's it's it's a i
mean dude when somebody has your phone
what do you feel like weird
depends who right defense yes okay i was
gonna say but like
a a friend
i would feel like they're going to
[ __ ] do something
look if i gave you my phone i know you
would do nothing
i think actually honestly here actually
here this is
interesting i just realized this if you
have friends that you believe would do
so if you're an adult let's say if
you're over the age of
25 and you have friends that you worry
would do something like that while
they're holding your phone
i don't know that shouldn't be something
that a friend of yours would do unless
it's like ah whatever [ __ ] it life if
they're like this kind of [ __ ] tom if
there's these tom cochrane kind of dudes
that are just driving into the sunset
it's like who gives a [ __ ] this is
what's like tommy cochran the highway
guy yeah okay i'm saying if you're just
like this guy who [ __ ] listens to
life as a highway on loop and you're
just like whatever comes my way i'm
gonna deal with it i [ __ ] with these
friends like they [ __ ] with me they live
by the golden rule which is absolute
[ __ ] by the way because you
shouldn't treat people the way you want
to be treated that's so self-centered
and egotistical you should treat people
the way you think they want to be that's
correct right so you can't be liking
pictures people's pictures if you know
if you're such good friends you should
know that about your friend yeah you
should know that about your friend about
it
why did you give your friend your phone
no no but but here's the thing why are
you on facebook dude get off of facebook
get off of facebook but also if i have
friends and they give me their phone i
would [ __ ] not do that but i might be
more likely to do it to another friend i
would not do that but i might be more
likely to do it to somebody it depends
on the relationship so you're gonna know
your relationships bro this guy needs to
know his relationship here's the advice
from us and then we should move on i
think moving forward
we generally won't actually agree that
much but i think we agree in that you
should right now
reassess your friendships yeah there you
go and and figure out who things like
not just this but things like who you
would trust with holding your phone your
phone
also
don't be on facebook yeah yeah facebook
is terrible because it's not because
it's not 2008 i know that guy looked
young he didn't look like he was [ __ ]
70 years old yeah which is the only
people that use facebook anymore all
right let's get another one what do we
got
glad we could help you so players oh how
do i tell my friends i'm doing the
sideways mambo with my ex
how do i tell my friends first of all
what's up players that's us yeah it's
amazing how do i tell my friends that
i'm doing the
sh it's a horizontal yeah he [ __ ] it
up he [ __ ] it up sideways but that's
okay he maybe he does his own mambo it's
fine yeah
sideways mambo right yes he's a sideways
mambo how do i tell my friends i'm doing
the sideways mambo with my ex which for
those who don't know that means he's
having sex with his ex yeah uh well why
first of all why do you need to tell him
i mean i think he's i because he wants
to live honestly yes he wants to live
honestly and his friends
what he's what he's doing doesn't want
to be duplicitous and [ __ ] yeah okay
yeah almost to be able to do it out in
the open and be able to talk about it
free and not be like right being
secretive right totally write it out on
a scroll put it in a pigeon's [ __ ]
hand and then send it over down the
street to your friend no i look i
actually get here's the deal
we didn't get much details because that
was like a [ __ ] five second video he
was on the plane
hilarious was he on the plane was he no
okay well whatever that would be great
if he was just doing it in the [ __ ]
middle in the middle seat
hey what's up
what's up players how am i i'm doing the
horizontal mamba with my ex and then
like this like so going to tucson
sideways mambo but yeah
uh okay so i think
what i'm
look if it was just like they just broke
up and now they're back together he
wouldn't be seeing advice what i'm
sensing is
they had a bad breakup or or somehow the
the the ex was toxic right in a way
maybe uh
and and and his friends know better and
are like
this guy shouldn't be get back together
with his ex so i think his the source of
his concern or worry about telling his
friends i think baked into that is
what's implied is this idea that he
probably shouldn't be doing it in the
first place yeah right because if you
just break up with somebody and it's
just like it was a decent fine breakup
whatever and then like a few months or
years even later you're like oh you know
what why did we break up it was such a
good relationship and i still have
feelings for her or him whatever
uh i don't think telling your friends
would be even an issue at all but what
i'm getting is that there's some problem
with their relationship or the ex
herself or himself i don't know it was a
six second video again it should have
been longer no six seconds is good
honestly
i mean we didn't get enough so fast how
you said it sucks
all right so
i no but i think you're supposing a lot
though you don't know okay you just
gotta take what he said the advice there
is
just tell them and don't be like look i
know i should no no no just do you do
what you're doing the heart wants what
the heart wants
tell your [ __ ] friends and that's
that all that [ __ ] should be on a
hallmark card you walk into your
friend's house you say guys all go over
to jim's house you go everyone gets old
to jim's house maybe i'll be there at 3
30. at 3 30 you show up you open the
door and you go like this guys i'm i'm
doinking her again and then spin out and
walk out to your car and leave and then
they know dude and you let them deal
with it then they know they're they have
one less friend than they did right
before that because that would be the
strangest [ __ ] [ __ ] that dude that
would be amazing and you know it dude if
your friend got all your friends
together and he had a horrible ex and a
month later he
said you guys all get together and then
get together at [ __ ] matt's house and
he shows up and he goes like this guys
just wanna let you know
i'm doinking her again and spun already
had his legs crossed so he could do i'm
doinking her so he could spit out and go
to his [ __ ] car and leave that would
be amazing i think a lot of them would
be having fun with life is what i think
a lot of them would be confused those
aren't really your friends you need to
know me bro if they're confused because
i said
you know spawn around and move yeah i
don't think that means they're not good
friends yeah it does dude he should no
you should know them look at that guy
he's got long hair and no beard i don't
trust anybody like that he's obviously
worried a good point but he's obviously
worried about it in some way and i think
because he's worried about it he should
just
tell them
and if they don't like it
it's their business and it's on them to
tell him yeah but he shouldn't [ __ ]
stress about it though but our heart
wants what the heart wants i know but
are you being too a little bit too much
dr phil about it and not having enough
fun with it because what he could do is
be unapologetically himself
move into a [ __ ] house with a bunch
of his friends there and do a crazy snap
spin move say i'm doing it and then spin
out and it's like he's being
unapologetically himself but also having
fun with it how do you know that's an
unapology that that's a specific thing
to do how do you know that was an honest
thing to do to do that i don't but i'm
saying figure out how to have fun with
it because it's a [ __ ] you know what
i mean it's not the end of the world
dude you're going to do what you're
going to do anyway your friends aren't
going to stop you
yeah well that's my point so be
unapologetically you which is
unapologetically he wants to join his ex
so tell your friends in a [ __ ] in the
way that you want to do it
right but he's asking him how to tell
advice so therefore i think he doesn't
know how and i think the way to do it
is to just say
hey you know what
i'm i've got i'm starting to consider
getting back together with my ex
and if he wants to he can add something
like i know you guys don't like her i
know you guys are whatever whatever
whatever but the heart wants what the
heart wants no stop saying that why
would you keep saying it's so annoying
to say [ __ ] these coin terms it's
just it's true though okay the heart
does want what the heart wants but we
all know that though
no we don't yeah we know that the heart
wants what the heart wants he's worried
about what his friends are gonna think
but the heart wants what the heart wants
yeah and his friends know i agree i
agree he can walk in and say hey friends
you know that the heart wants what the
heart wants no right you shouldn't do
that but no but i'm saying all of his
friends would be like that's the thing
about the heart they wouldn't no not one
of his dudes would be like no actually i
don't know man sometimes it's actually
more what the head wants but he's
getting ahead of it by telling by
prefacing it with he's saying the heart
wants with the heroine so that they
can't
sort of get at him from another angle
because he sort of covered himself in
the safety of the heart wants what the
hell it wants i guess so man
yeah i guess so i think he's making it
too much of an issue already by asking
for advice about it you just got to do
what you're going to do which you're
already drinking your ex so just tell
your friends and do it in the most
unapologetic way you want to because
you're you bro and if you want to donk
your ex your friends aren't going to
stop you so continue to do that
horizontal mamba with her as long as you
want
yeah
yeah i mean i don't i think you're
stressing the unapologetic thing too
much
what if what if what if what if you
never know right because you're saying
going around straight about it tell them
what's up so you don't have to live in
the shadows you [ __ ] say what say
what you're gonna say clear it up get it
out and that's it okay cool and when you
doinker just remember it's in the way
that you use it your personality so go
ahead
next one what do we got
hi chris and matt my name is meg and i'm
pregnant with my first son
hey i cannot believe it and i need to
know borrowing a little bit from chris's
language here but i know matt you'll be
very familiar
what are the like top three things i
need to convey to my son as early as day
one
to ensure that he has a life that rips
that is my question for you i know that
you'll have some great advice appreciate
you guys thanks
cute wow that's awesome a [ __ ] dad so
you should take this one i i although
let me just say real quick and so you
didn't mean it i didn't yeah
there's really only one
[ __ ]
respect the kid it's a deeper for
whatever the [ __ ]
he is
he wants don't try to put your [ __ ] on
him
take what he gives you and respect that
and try to foster that
nope it's a deeper yes and it's all good
but it's a deeper issues and that's fine
okay but what i'm saying is yes you do
obviously need to respect your son or
otherwise he won't he'll grow up and
learn to not respect you right
no i'm just adding what you said it's a
deeper and by the way if it's a deeper
whatever you it's deeper for me but i
retaliated on you
but um just like i advised the first guy
to not do i retaliated on you because
you deserved it exactly but i didn't
deserve it you did why because it's a
deeper yeah i didn't like it okay well
so look
uh
you gotta [ __ ] said three so i know
and that's all that's a lofty i mean
she's asking you know let's do what we
can no she wants three give me three
take the one and use that one and then
okay two okay so i have one so far okay
so if i have one and we might have more
but what i'm saying is
absolutely you gotta you gotta talk to
him a lot in the beginning talk to him
like a person like have full sentences
with him i did that with calvin and this
[ __ ]
won't stop talking i know all about him
and the quicker you can know about your
son or daughter the more you can learn
about them and the early on experiences
with them will help shape them into who
they become and that's only a good thing
if you can have communication with them
from jump and it will be one-sided
because you'll be saying something like
do you want a banana and they'll just be
doing like that
but if you can then
understand that if they understand
you're talking to them that's the first
step into them communicating back to you
right so
i think that that's a number one thing
is communication i think that probably a
lot of people would say that the respect
thing yes of course you want to respect
it but also uh you need to you know
respect kind of comes later like they're
just [ __ ] their parents yeah but a
lot of parents want
yeah sure obviously in the first three
months they don't want anything because
they don't even have a [ __ ] brain yet
really yeah i'm just saying so many
parents that i've encountered in my life
want their kid
and i don't mean like in terms of
morality or ethics obviously you have to
instill morality and ethics in your
child to be a good person yeah but i'm
just saying what they're what their
interests are
always like allow them to guide you not
the other way around oh you know oh yeah
and here's another thing too um it's a
deeper but yeah so here's another thing
um is another thing is um
when you
like
like
like when i say to you hey let's go get
a pizza and you're like i don't want
pizza
i could maybe say like
nah come on man right
you're a [ __ ] 30 something year old
man yeah and you'll be like nah [ __ ] you
i don't want pizza right i mean that
would be so rude no but not not if we
have a certain dynamic ask me if i want
pizza you want pizza [ __ ] you no no
that's too quick if i'm saying do you
want pizza
you say no no ah come on [ __ ] let's
get pizza
i'm not i don't want pizza okay you do
it to me this is okay too do you want
pizza i know i don't want pizza come on
you love pizza come on man get the [ __ ]
out of here let's get a bagel that's not
that bad
i mean if you're my kid that would be oh
no i'm saying i'm saying as an adult
though okay yeah i'm not saying as a kid
okay
um that's okay to do as an adult as a
kid obviously you're not gonna do that
but say like when i go to hug calvin
he's two but sometimes he hugs me but
sometimes he goes no no no no no right
and then if i go ah come on ah yeah
that's not respecting
what he wants right yeah yeah yes yeah
so so i'm adding to what you're saying
yes so
at a really early age that can that can
affect it like even eye contact [ __ ] my
therapist was telling me this like if
you're looking at the baby and the
baby's not looking at you and you're
like hey i'm over here and then it looks
away you're like no i'm over here that
that can [ __ ] a baby up right that could
[ __ ] them up right yeah yeah yeah i
think the other thing is too my
therapist actually
had a while i was
had a baby
well actually i'm telling the story so
but for the part that i'm gonna
say and then ask questions if that is
what it is though then in the middle
like i think four or five years in she
had a son so that is what it is okay but
i was telling a story and i didn't want
you to [ __ ] interrupt and it's fine
and when she came back she was obviously
a mother now and she was very excited
and i was very happy for her and i was
asking her questions usually obviously
you know it's it's about me but i was
interested in
her experience on the therapist and i
was like aren't you worried about uh
holy [ __ ] that was close yeah aren't you
worried about we have andre ryzen works
for us and he just throws them
uh
aren't you worried about like especially
as a therapist all the ways that you can
[ __ ] your son up uh-huh and she actually
said something that i i think about all
the time but where did you get off she
said she said
well i'm going to
it's just a matter of
hey not making it worse once i do it and
b being
not so hard on myself when i do it and
understanding that all i can do is try
to be better moving forward i can't undo
what i've done or
try so hard to not [ __ ] him up that i'm
sort of like [ __ ] up in in a new way
that i'm creating on my own yeah it's
like
walking around on eggshells so much can
be its own way of [ __ ] him up is what
she was saying yeah i hope that when
you're saying that the edit just slowly
zooms in on my face the whole time
you're saying on your face yeah
oh well that's selfish um because i get
that but it's also like you can [ __ ]
your life up like that it's really
interesting um
it's really interesting that there's
really
like life is just hard and being a mom
or dad is hard yeah and you're going to
[ __ ] up yeah what if you when you said
to your therapist what do you think
about that she said i'm going to and she
and she goes like this that's all the
time we have um but yeah so you're gonna
[ __ ] it up and uh
and that's sad but it's also beautiful
right yeah i don't think it's sad i
think it's just reality it's like you're
gonna
how could you possibly be a perfect
parent what would that even mean that
would be its own way of [ __ ] up
right you know right that was too loud
the quickly
paper thing i didn't like that but but
what you said was loud so i i did it
while you were talking this way you
wouldn't have heard it so now you just
addressed it no it threw me off and i
didn't like it at all
you should have done it when you were
talking so i think that that's great
that's about three things we gave her
congratulations though i think that
that's awesome you look like she's gonna
be a great mom you could tell she's got
a mickey and company shirt on she seemed
i don't know what that is but she seemed
very excited too she's very excited
that's very cool god bless man i love be
i love being a dad as you know if you
listen to congratulations and it's just
the best thing man it's just so wild
all right okay let's go to the next one
let's do another one how long have we
been by the way hi chris and matt um i
love the idea for this podcast i'm super
excited thank you um
so something that i think people need to
hear or at least for myself advice that
i would like
is how
and what do you think is the most
effective way to get over like a
friendship breakup like when you're so
close to someone and you get so used to
like talking to that person every day
and sharing parts of your life with them
and then
you stop
but then there's like mutual friends
involved
and it's just awkward and uncomfortable
like you used to be so close to that
person and now you're not like
how do you handle that like how do you
cope with that i know some people would
say like oh it's nothing like just move
on from it but
for me somebody who struggles with
anxiety
i get so anxious about stuff like that
like just knowing i'm gonna walk in the
room and see those people like what are
some ways to kind of combat that i don't
know um i appreciate any and all
feedback because you know life
consistently rips
that's a good [ __ ] question
judo judo you can jut you can do judo
well physically no assault ah
interesting you should say that no not
physically well okay then it [ __ ]
explains emotional judo because when
people think about judo they think about
the martial art but i'm mr beyond the
box and i'll tell you this
judo
is a thing where you use your enemy or
whoever you're fighting in a friendly
way uh you use their energy and momentum
uh in combination to thwart them right
give me an example so she walks in a
room while i give you an ex-friend is
there i'll give you example with judo
you throw a punch no i don't [ __ ]
stop it like this like i'm batman i move
with it you know what i mean you throw a
punch and i go oh the punch is coming
well let me go in the direction of the
punch and by the way let me redirect the
punch like this and catch it like this
and whoopsie daisy i [ __ ] your elbow
up right b stephen seagals yeah
basically aikido okay that's aikido not
judo and that's hilarious because it's
unclear
and it's not a perfect example for very
obvious reasons give me an example bring
it to her like what she walks into a
room emotional judo now here's the deal
you walk into a room and she's gonna be
in there guess what dude
guess what if you think it's awkward she
thinks it's awkward yes that's a good
first thought so now you know that right
yeah she might not be thinking that she
might be thinking well this is awkward
because a lot of people don't go beyond
that they just think about what's going
on in themselves which is what she's
doing right now that's why she's sending
the video yes but i've been in a lot of
these situations i've been on stage
people have thrown pencils at me i've
been on stage and people have said boo
[ __ ] you next i know what that's like
but what i know also is how that person
feels after they say it
oh [ __ ] i'm singled out whoops oh oh i'm
[ __ ]
i feel weird right so now that i know
that you feel weird what i do is i use
that to my advantage and now i'm the
powerful one so i think what you can do
is first of all there's really one step
in this realize that they feel awkward
right yeah and your anxiety can lessen
because you know their anxiety there's
only so much anxiety that can fill a
room right and if her anxiety is going
up yours is going down because you're in
the power position so if you could milk
that that would be the most gangster
[ __ ] right like if you walked into a
party and whoopsie daisy rebecca is
there okay and you don't have a
friendship anymore because of the
falling out whatever it happened she
[ __ ] your ex whatever it is you know
she stole some money from you you walk
into the room and you walk into some
[ __ ] really confidently and you just go
like this you walk up right up to her
you walk right up to her and you just
put your hands softly on the table and
you say
everybody rebecca's here dude you win
yeah this was so [ __ ] confrontational
though not really you are you clapping
on the way over yes on the way over
you're clapping she's [ __ ] or you can
even you can even imagine where you play
the [ __ ] banjo i'm gonna go on a limb
and say that's not really what she's
looking for i know i'm saying she asked
what she should do okay you can go in
and play the imaginary [ __ ] mandolin
and just walk in and it'll be weird
because it'll be like oh [ __ ] she's here
oh and what's she going to say to
rebecca and you're just like this right
and you walk in and then you [ __ ] go
like this and you go like this you go
like this
rebecca's here everybody
you could do that and that would you
could definitely do that yeah i agree
i agree with that but not a lot of
people are gonna do that let's be honest
and that's a shame well
whether it's a shame or not it's it's
the truth okay even you would agree with
that not a lot of people i would do it
i have done something i'm not answering
what i'm saying
you're just saying that you would do it
okay yeah but i think that i actually
think you're right the first thing is to
yes this is a big big big thing that i
think is always good to keep in mind to
do the class obviously we are us we are
only one person we're two people but but
we know
that
it's good to remember that other people
are also experiencing whatever we the
individual are all are feeling we don't
usually go past that it's like
we feel [ __ ] up everyone else seems so
normal trust me your friend well i don't
know if it's male or female whatever
they're not feeling normal they feel
[ __ ] weird and [ __ ] up too so that
is actually right where you go wrong i
think
this thing
and then you come up and say everybody
rebecca's here i don't think that's the
best why do you think that that's wrong
because it draws so much attention to it
and i don't think she's trying to make
it hit it worse hit it head on it's not
going to be worse i think the way to
deal with it though is to just
know that it's awkward for everybody and
don't do the thing where you're
constantly averting your eyes i think
this is a big one you don't always look
away it's it it it this shouldn't matter
but it does it projects weakness yeah i
think you just look at the person if
they're talking play the imaginary
mandolin don't don't play the imaginary
mandolin
don't do that ever okay
you look you just look at the person if
they're talking don't look at them when
they're not and even if here's the deal
even if
it's really [ __ ] awkward
don't let it seem like it is yes and and
i'm and i'm not advocating that you be
dishonest
for
the the reason i'm out i'm suggesting
that is because it really is true that
the once you start to act like that and
people are picking up on the fact that
you don't seem like you're awkward or
uncomfortable yeah
once that is in other people's heads it
will be way easier for you
to act or actually feel not just act but
actually feel like it doesn't matter
once you're getting the feedback the the
the sort of like energetic response of
other people being like oh
she doesn't even really seem to [ __ ]
care then that'll give you sort of more
uh
confidence to to to to actually not
give a [ __ ] so do things like chew gum
pick up smoking things that keep you
active and like doing things so you're
not sitting there with your hands in
your pockets like this if you're around
no that would be really strong stillness
is the strongest [ __ ] thing right
stillness is
people [ __ ] notice that [ __ ] and it
really starts people i mean also just
don't pick up smoking right no i mean
but i'm saying jewel or vaping but yeah
um she vapes already do you think she
vapes yeah for sure but um
my i think that
the opposite of what you're saying
uh you're saying
uh
you were saying that
don't
be
or seem awkward because they're awkward
and what i'm you're saying don't be
awkward and i'm saying the opposite of
being awkward is
slow clapping walking up maybe playing
some imaginary mandolin looking into
their eyes and saying everybody
rebecca's here right then you're making
everyone else awkward no but but that's
the thing rule it rule the awkwardness
you know how batman's like the guy's
like oh [ __ ] who are you and he's
like i am vengeance dude i am awkward
okay i i understand but you don't need
to add to it or be the instigator of
awkwardness it's already there but are
you what you want to seem like is that
you don't care are you adding to it
if you
have none of it no there's only enough
awkwardness to fill the room guess what
i'm depleting my awkwardness but it's
not just about you without next one it's
about
i mean next one sure but it's not just
about you it's about everybody else
and the mandolin thing and then looking
in her eyes and saying everybody
rebecca's here okay let's do another one
okay
that's a [ __ ] how we started you guys
are doing a show together i gotta make
this quick so it fits um basically a
year ago i was traveling beautiful eyes
costa rica he's a beautiful girl at a
hostel her friend invited me to travel
so i traveled with them for four weeks
eventually
you know they had to go back up to
france i had to go back home to hawaii
um and in the meantime i fell in love
with this girl we kept in touch
now we talk every couple months um but
i'm moving to france in the fall
and i'm going to pursue this chick she
doesn't know i'm moving there she knows
i'm coming to visit i'm gonna tell her
before i go that i'm moving um
but yeah she's a couple years older than
me she's french
um
she speaks pretty good english i don't
speak any french and yeah i'm head over
heels in love with her she's beautiful
she's
but here
is a hundred drawings i don't know if
i'm gonna she
this is cute but i'm gonna do a hundred
dollars and yeah so basically roast me
please give me advice love you guys i
wish i could get more details but i
gotta go
love you all and the producers and matt
and everyone and chris sore
okay cool love you back
hold on
did he say in the middle of that
i talked to her now every couple of
months no he didn't say that of course
not he said something like that i talk
to her now every couple of
minutes
no no i swear he said something like
that dude okay well he talks to her more
than every couple months okay so let's
start there here we go let's just play
it again so excited you guys are doing
so here we go i gotta make this quick so
it fits um basically a year ago i was
traveling in costa rica i met a girl at
a hostel my christian friend invited me
to travel so i traveled with them for
like four weeks eventually
you know they had to go back up to
france i had to go back home to hawaii
and in the meantime i fell in love with
this girl we kept in touch for a little
bit now we
talk every couple months
but i'm moving to
[Music]
you're france in the fantasy land
he just misspoke obviously
stalking
he misspoke
craze dude this isn't okay
let's hope you misspoke
this is okay
knock knock who's there
he cries no he she knows he's coming oh
i'll tell you he's coming every night
dude while he's drawing those pictures
jacking off hey you drawing 100 pictures
to somebody to talk to every two months
do you really think he meant you don't
think he misspoke we've got to redo the
video if you misspo i mean i agree with
that i mean how long has it been two
months i talked to every two months i
talked to her once
crazy dude
hey guy
i mean dude that's insane you dress so
much like you're in the 90s and the fact
that i'm not even
broaching that topic because
he crazed he's just dropped a [ __ ]
bomb he's dressed so much like a guy
that goes backpacking through europe
he did no i know that's what i'm saying
hey guy
change no be nice okay i know be nice
he's in love he's following his heart he
met her he fell in love oh my god dude
he missed i hope you misspoke dude this
french girl is in france with her
husband like yeah i
no i didn't meet anybody she doesn't
even know well now we don't know that at
all we don't know anything about her he
fell in love with her let's hear here
here's what he's drawn 100 let's assume
okay that
she
reciprocates his feelings okay just for
the sake of okay right i think he
misspoke i do too otherwise
i feel i feel pretty [ __ ] certain
yeah
here's the thing the fact that he's
planning on moving there and hasn't told
her yet that's a big one
that's not good everything is bad about
this tell her now okay no no no no no no
no
no
no no no wrong first of all you recorded
it in the bathroom
echoey
recorded okay everything is wrong from
jumping but no no no no the whole
i mean chris is dying i know he's gonna
leave you can laugh in the mic it's okay
okay go ahead
i i think
the the sentiment in general the idea
that he fell in love and is picking up
and leaving his life behind for love
that's not wrong that in itself is not
wrong that is that's not wrong that is
quite beautiful actually the issue here
is that he's planning on moving and
hasn't told her i know he said he's
gonna that needs to be a conversation
though is he moving for her or is he
moving
i mean a [ __ ] he's moving for her
what do you mean made the taunted
drawings he crazed and it's all good but
the thing is dude he made a hundred
drawing he's going to do 100 by the way
that drawing was absolutely [ __ ]
fantastic i thought it was a hallmark
card okay
but um 100 of them yeah 100 of them it's
gonna take some time but that's okay
because he's talking and the thing is
um what this is what i was going to say
about this uh you
have to tell her and is also
talking to her is cool do that more to
make sure she's in the same boat dude
come on okay if you misspoke then yes
but i'm sure he misspoke i'm sure he
misspoke let's just say he misspoke but
um
i think that you need to
uh
really have the conversation with her
immediately yeah because also what if
she sees this i mean this is already one
of the most popular podcasts of all but
also
you can't trust a guy that says hawaii
no yeah you can he's from there it
doesn't matter it's like how people from
people from that they hooked up
i don't know i don't know if he did say
that i don't know did he say that they
hooked up or not no i don't know he
didn't specify you don't love anybody
that you didn't do the [ __ ]
horizontal mumble with i'll tell you
that much
you need to be connected physically and
also mentally mentally
and emotionally
mentally and physically to [ __ ] love
someone otherwise and i hate to say this
and you know i do but it craze
he's in love with her let's just take it
at his [ __ ] word
whether he
is in the criteria the [ __ ] rubric
that you've invented he feels like he's
in love with her therefore he is okay
okay
so phil but okay hawaii he's leaving
hawaii and he's got e he's going to
perry
yes
to
reunite with the woman that he loves
yeah dude he's gonna be doing this a lot
in paris by the way
right
right right right okay i'm saying i'm
just doing a lot of this impair
oh because he's stuck
because he's stalking yeah right right
100 i'm only on 72 i moved too early
but i think that i don't think
anything beyond [ __ ]
teller and if she is happy about it then
everything is good
and if you [ __ ] don't tell her and
just do it there's there should be an
independent movie about you from 1998
yeah and how you're a [ __ ] crazy
stalker and you end up killing starring
nobody wants ethan hawk yeah
yeah definitely not a french woman like
a famous french
and for sure [ __ ]
uh get super fat in like 10 years anyway
dude
also
uh [ __ ] i keep forgetting what i'm gonna
say because i get derailed but uh
blaming me if you didn't if you didn't
sleep with her
let me tell you if you didn't sleep you
probably don't you're probably not in
love it's probably an infatuation and
also if you if you
she he said she talks pretty good
english yes you don't
you can't connect on physically or
with words
if you talk pretty good english that's
like hi you know going back to the
ukraine [ __ ] how are you we have good
times here like you can't fall in love
with somebody like that you can do that
that is the worst thing you've said this
entire [ __ ] episode so far you can
follow you're saying you can only follow
people perfectly speak the same language
perfectly no i mean how many people in
america alone americans alone
met their wives overseas like when they
were in the [ __ ] british people oh no
how's it going i don't know language
like [ __ ] vietnamese women and [ __ ]
no oh dude that's where i draw the line
these dudes these creepy white dudes who
have that asian kink okay but that's i'm
not talking about [ __ ] asian kings
i'm talking about people falling in love
with people don't speak perfect english
because they're demure and [ __ ] and they
just have a power problem okay but okay
yeah
i know it's a deeper but yeah it's not
about
the language thing okay that is a
completely non
that has nothing to do with any of that
all right i don't know if it has nothing
to do with it but okay
to [ __ ]
tell her that's the meaning you're
moving to her country yes from hawaii
yes
that's it okay
and i do i think you're crazy or not
crazy i don't think anything
until i hear her [ __ ] response i like
the guy i appreciate the guy i honestly
appreciate the guy i think the guy's a
good guy i think he misspoke but if he
didn't i still like the guy yeah and we
all are going through some [ __ ] dude
yeah we are all going through some [ __ ]
and i appreciate you as a listener
it craze
i don't i don't necessarily agree look
if she feels the same about him as he
does for her that's true she could be
over the [ __ ] moon about the fact
he's gonna wind up dead
totally true either way someone's going
to wind up dead let's do it next one
okay
the [ __ ] wasted hey chris hey matt my
name is aaron i'm 18. i absolutely love
congratulations i watched every single
podcast
and i especially love the ones with matt
so i'm really excited for lifeline
i was wondering if you guys had any
advice on how to deal with people with
zero [ __ ] social awareness first of
all you're working chick-fil-a so i have
to deal with these people every day and
so for instance this one time you know
i'm working down a huge huge line i like
this of people and i mean
i'm asking this guy how his night is and
he starts rambling about his heart
problems he has kidney problems his
lungs aren't doing that great he has a
skin condition so this guys
are just [ __ ] done
and he ends up dropping this bombshell
that the doctor told he had like two
months to live like i don't know if this
guy was [ __ ] with me but i'm kind of
inclined to believe him because he was
in his like 70s so
i guess you guys probably have dealt
with some stuff like this potentially
you do you have a lot of fans and you
know you're trying to get the other [ __ ]
in your day yeah so anyways
thank you for listening to this and i
hope you have some advice for me oh this
guy's cool i like you're just saying
look i like him too you're just saying
that because he's wearing your [ __ ]
merch and that pisses me off i thought
you knew me thought you knew me that's
not true you know you know kind of guy
that i would [ __ ] meet and be like
this guy's hilarious
he's got a great voice he should be on
the radio you should be on the radio
comb your hair a little bit but you know
his hair's fine that's a good style i
know bro looks like half of his head was
in half of his head ah half of his head
was in a corvette the other half was
like meeting his girlfriend's mother you
know what i mean yeah but it's also like
dude bro you're 18.
do your hair
he did do his hair didn't do it you
think he needs to roll out of bed and
hit record
i either think that or the day got the
best of him and he didn't check the
mirror before he sent in no no no no no
no no no no okay i'm just saying he
likes shirt he likes his hair like that
honestly so do i that seems cool you're
being [ __ ] you just looked at my hair
i didn't like that
okay well so here's the deal dude um
i have
okay
the old me
four years ago would have said
if i worked at chick-fil-a and said hey
sir
um
what would you like how's your day and
if he said i'm actually dying soon
i would
say
wow that's crazy
what would you like though right because
i'm not your therapist dude can i just
add something i think i think and i
don't know maybe i'm assuming this i
think this happened when he was giving
the guy his food not when he was taking
his order that would be amazing to hold
up the line and being like i have kidney
failure well he could have been waiting
for his food to be done yeah no i'm
saying that's what i'm saying you i hope
you're right yeah right okay right so
he's like hi i'll have a number two and
then goes great cool cool got it yeah
anyway got in so how was your day wow
well you know it's crazy i tell you my
my skin's yellow from [ __ ] having
diabetes and also uh my kidney's failing
and i have cancer and the doctor gave me
two months to live right right so uh
that's too much information do you want
any sauces with that yeah yeah that's
too much information to unload on anyone
period yeah so only do it to your really
close friends and family maybe he
doesn't have it he's obviously a lonely
guy but i guarantee the next person that
is not your best friend on your friend
list is the guy you just ordered a
crispy chicken sandwich from right so
that's too much for that guy that guy's
got major problems and if he's gonna die
in two months we understand why that's a
huge mental toll to [ __ ] take off
right exactly he could be like on not
unstable but right but
sort of [ __ ] frazzled and doesn't
know how to
you could maybe take that into account
when considering what the [ __ ] to do
with this guy so what i think that you
do is you say well you know i understand
why now you're eating chick-fil-a it's
not good for you but what do you have to
lose so here's some extra chicken
sandwiches and you give it to them and
then if you get fired for that for
giving away free food you go online and
you go on a tirade saying like
chick-fil-a not only do they not support
homosexuals they also don't want guys to
live yeah and have fun in their last two
months of life and then guess what dude
you [ __ ] pretty much will become
famous and get money from it and get
hired at a better job possibly that's
exactly what i'm talking about with the
judo [ __ ] he took it the momentum and
turned it into [ __ ] spun it into gold
this guy's basically
everybody rebecca's here okay stop
talking about judo for real though
because it doesn't apply here at all i
think also i don't think he's
specifically asking about how to deal
with this guy because this guy's never
coming back he's [ __ ] dead before the
next time he goes to chick-fil-a he's
asking about people who are socially
awkward when he can't escape the
situation oh i know what to do then all
right you look in her eyes and you go
i once was allowed to serve the term as
office boy twenty twenties from i clean
your windows and i [ __ ] up floors i
apologize but this week to embarrass you
so carefully and now in the rule of the
queen's navy and you say that was from
hms pinafore your turn yeah and then
they don't know what to do i i mean i
actually agree with that it doesn't have
to be exactly that but you do a musical
now right that to me is look that's
[ __ ] rough and if somebody spills
their [ __ ] about them dying soon there's
not really much you can do besides just
wait until they [ __ ] drive off which
will inevitably inevitably happen soon
but in general when people do awkward
[ __ ] make you like bring up [ __ ] you
don't want to talk about
that isn't so [ __ ] heavy and tough to
talk about
just do like whatever they made you
[ __ ] awkward and sprung some [ __ ] you
don't want to talk about
do the same [ __ ] thing to them that's
[ __ ] annoying that guy
is an exception i would say but in
general about annoying people [ __ ] them
dude just do whatever say something
annoying to me be like oh dude you know
what are you gonna say no i'm dying but
like i don't know you and you're like
hey what's up with [ __ ] you know
native americans or something
be annoying to me say that native
american what do i say i don't know
anything be like hey do you like the new
prius
hey do you like the new prius i'll put a
sign up right in the front window
advertisement writer in the front window
and all of a sudden success coming out
of the blue little shop bar is your turn
you don't know what to say i would say
anyway can i have some ranch or
something like that and get the [ __ ] out
of there because i don't want to talk to
you thwart them
yeah there you have it
that's that that honestly that's the one
that i agree with you on so that's right
that's a good one i agree i agree with
me on all of them but uh yeah you don't
agree with yourself in fact that's not
even the right word you can do that
and i did that
well you can do anything but it doesn't
make any sense well okay
my point is that was the show and we did
it is there more we're done we're done
we did it over an hour right oh we're
done okay cool okay and uh
and that's great that's the show
lifeline dude we this was fun this was
fun and hit the email what's the email
ask chris and matt gmail.com ask chris
and matt
gmail.com i can't believe that that
wasn't taken already honestly
like and subscribe to this [ __ ]
to the channel we're gonna have the
second episode of lifeline uh next week
and we're just gonna keep on rolling
them out every week dude this is your
new favorite podcast and do you know why
because it's about you
we discuss the advices that you need
yeah i mean we we do really
and this was fun i didn't expect here's
the deal i didn't expect it to not be
fun i didn't know what to expect but it
was fun and that is [ __ ] nice yeah
and also phoenix i'll be in your city
april 30th uh get tickets at
crystallia.com and i'm going to be put
going on more tours and [ __ ] like that
and who knows if this show blows up
maybe we'll do some live shows and los
angeles i will be in los angeles because
i'm always in [ __ ] los angeles but
you don't have a place here
you give advice to the people in the
comments that would be cool what do i do
no not you i'm just saying to the people
watching why don't you give advice in
the comment section to the people
because they're definitely going to be
reading it for sure no but really what
do i do i'm seeking your advice oh um
i guess just keep doing this podcast
every week okay all right thanks guys
thank you
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
hello